democrats getting very nervous over next
week's virginia governor's race and new
fox polling spelling absolute disaster
for terry mcauliffe republican glenn
younkin surging ahead of mcauliffe he's
now up by eight mcauliffe not left with
a lot of options to turn things around
the deeply unpopular kamala harris is
set to campaign with him today
so
he continues to claim the outrage over
education in the state is fake news
how are you going to work with those
parents who have concerns
about how things are being taught in
schools
let's be very clear here this is all
generated by glenn yonko they try to
find a divisive tactic this is a racist
dog whistle and i hate it because it's
pitting parents against parents and
parents against teachers
all right katie speaking of racist dog
whistle they had a little false flag
that blew up in the makov campaign's
face today what'd they do they put a
bunch of white guys with tiki torches
oh yeah before they pulled the stunt
they checked off all the diversity boxes
that the left has you got to have a
woman you got to have a person of color
they allowed the white males to show up
at this event so at a young event today
in charlottesville uh four democrats who
were tied to the virginia democratic
party showed up in the same khaki pants
uh brand new tiki torches with maybe the
stat the tag still on them the same
white shirts and like random camo hats
you know and then of course the media
picked up on and said look at these
white supremacists who showed up to back
glenn younkin so you know twitter did
its thing and conservative reporters got
on and found out you know their their
twitter profiles and that they all work
for virginia democrats and maybe just
maybe some of them may actually work for
the mcauliffe campaign they got caught
they deny it they try it let me say they
deny it but they're not the most honest
campaign right and the left takes white
supremacy very seriously so i'm sure
if they weren't involved they'll be
calling the fbi to track down these
white supremacists because they are very
very dangerous people so they brought it
to play on cnn
they realized they were running around
they probably wet themselves yeah
exactly so this does not sound like
a confident campaign greg well right i
mean it's amazing biden showing up did
not help
he shows up he was like the guest at a
dinner party that throws up in the
buffet because it was just everybody
said oh my god this is going to be great
but this what we're seeing is a really
amazing phenomenon parents are woke in
the in the good sense they've woken up
they've they had no idea for the longest
time how much contempt that the teachers
unions and the teachers and
i guess edu the whole educational system
has for them and that their intent is to
brainwash the kids this is the this is
the positive aspect of covid that's
where the parents learned all this at
home they saw how left-wing their
teachers were how they hate the kids how
they hate them so this isn't just about
virginia this is an education problem
writ large it's this is the time to
wrestle control from this monstrous
monolith the evidence is there everybody
at home saw it on their zoom their zoom
classes and now according to the
washington post education is the top
issue in this race yeah it is in
virginia we've seen all these board
meetings loudoun county school board
fairfax county school board all of these
suburbs of d.c which makes you think the
doj memo that came out a couple weeks
ago that was talking about parents as
potential threats has that now blown up
on democrats and on this administration
because that made parents who were
already upset now feeling like somebody
was coming potentially after their first
amendment rights that's the way they
many of them interpreted it um it's been
a backlash for mcauliffe ever since then
because what a parents have said is like
oh not only do you have all these things
i disagree with but i'm supposed to sit
down and shut up and since that's
happened the numbers have continued to
tick down for mcauliffe we'll see
i mean we still have a few days together
he has a lot of momentum glenn younkin
any predictions jessica
i think it's going to be within the
margin of error that's not a prediction
no well it is it's going to it's
statistically tied at this point that's
greg angry yeah is this a voodoo doll by
the way if i stab him do you feel pain
oh oh it works
wrong so there were two other polls the
washington post and echelon insights
both put out a poll echelon had junken
up three washington post mcauliffe up
one but the education question is so
fascinating because now mcauliffe is
down 15 points with parents who have
kids ages kindergarten to 12th grade
that's a very big group and virginia now
it's not as blue as new jersey where
also phil murphy's in a tighter race
than he would like
new jersey will still stay blue but if
this becomes a wave of some kind with
these education voters when
the expectation is that we have jobs in
the economy voters or you have coveted
voters and that becomes the number one
issue there's going to be have to be a
big reversal in terms of the messaging
that's coming out about it and
republicans frankly you know junkin has
been smart he campaigns alone
he has not nationalized this race at all
he has fundraisers with high profile
republicans but when you go to a rally
you just see glenn youngkin and the
democrats are going to have to pay
attention to that because obviously
we've nationalized it but if it doesn't
work
in this scenario then going forward
we've got to think
about that new model for a republican
race yeah you guys have a lot of
thinking to do i think all the time
all right and little greg is going to
host the next segment so stick around
for the fastest
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else